what's up pretty babies welcome to
another episode of get close i am geo
and i'm bart
you know we've been together for a
pretty long time sadly
okay until i get to hear that
um
did you ever have like a favorite
i told you so moment oh my god like all
the time what's your favorite what's
your most recent or what's your most
favorite one a favorite one [ __ ]
that's the thing i don't keep telly yeah
so i don't know i just don't tally or
you have bad memory
maybe it's bad
but i don't hold on to things for that
long you know what i mean yeah you don't
hold on to things for that long or
you're not smart enough to remember
i don't know if [ __ ] smart has
anything to do with memory you [ __ ]
dick i think it does a little bit how do
you go i think and then try to give me a
statement
that's how the world works
um it's called the fouchy method
i don't i can't think of anything off
the top of my brain i can't think of
anything but i know there's a lot of
those moments where i'm like see
[ __ ] i'm always right
i think it's literally in our whole
relationship i think i'm always saying
that well that's good you'll say
something and i'm like i [ __ ] told
you oh [ __ ] like um something as petty
as like
when you drove into the lake in big bear
and i was like don't do it this is not
solid there's zero evidence of that
uh so everyone go to bart juan's
instagram
it's bart quan and then it's going to be
in the year 2019 yeah you remember the
year no i'm making it up i'm just
assuming it was 2019 because in 2020
it was before the pandemic for sure so
it's either 2018 or 2019 or 2017 one of
those i think it's 2017.
go on to youtube and watch the video but
i think it's 2017.
yeah that's the only one i can think of
but [ __ ] like that where i'm always
going like don't do this and then it
happens i'm like i told you it feels so
good oh my gosh why does it make you
feel so good because i'm right who
doesn't like feeling right
but don't you think that you never got
anything out of it it was just me
because no i get polite that's me having
fun though i get plenty at it because
it's you going uh fun police don't do
that that's not fun and then i do it and
look how fun that was then you go i told
you so i'm like well i still have my
phone well cool you get your fun but
then i get my validation of like i know
i'm right i know i'm right damn i think
i'm getting buff because like
either i'm just gaining a lot of weight
but damn this is feeling a little bit
tight here you like that my little
biceps yeah i love it oh okay i love it
i don't know if girls like doing their
clothes feel tighter
well i don't know if it's a guy girl
type of thing oh because i know guys for
sure well not around the midsection but
around the arms are like oh hell yeah
these these are nice well i do feel i
see my biceps and i feel them and i'm
like
oh you didn't have them before so you
feel strong no yeah i didn't really have
much muscle i was a [ __ ] skinny fat
[ __ ] that's my i told you so moment
cool
i didn't want it though so it doesn't
matter what you tell me i know but it
still feels good
that you knew i was going to like it
eventually no it's just like i feel like
for a long time of our period
hour period yeah where i'm like i i'm
like i think she's trained i think she's
trying i think she'll really train like
really put your mind to it and then you
um
uh were like not so about it but i'm
gonna trust me once you get the bug it's
gonna feel so good it's gonna feel your
whole life
and then it took a few years
but then the amount that i see you train
now it's like
wow that's awesome like i love how
committed and disciplined you are now
and like and how much you're getting
after it to the point where
that
feels better than i told you so
while you're i told you so that's more
elevated than mine no it's not because
i'm not done
because
the petty side of the way for the petty
side of me
the pace out of me is still like
i [ __ ] told you so you [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] you would have done this five
years earlier you'd be [ __ ] squatting
900 pounds god damn it you [ __ ] dumb
[ __ ] i told you so
yeah but i didn't want i don't want to
squat 900. i know just
whatever the message i get
i hid all the numbers i wanted to hit
[ __ ]
back in
i don't know 2016 or 15 or 14 or some
[ __ ]
your standards are that low very low 100
yeah i don't really care for strength
that much like i love strength don't get
me wrong i love feeling capable and
strong yeah but now i'm in the phase
where i'm like i just want to look fly
like i just want i want to i want that
bodybuilding [ __ ]
you want a bodybuilder body or you want
more of like uh the crossfit body oh
okay yeah the crossfit body because
bodybuilding for me
and what i observe it's um i still want
to be super athletic yeah whereas
bodybuilding it's very isolated
movements yeah yeah
why why why do you ask me this question
do you if do you have something in your
pocket that you're like
that was that was it that was the only
one yeah i was just thinking about like
what are the times in the relationship
that like
make you go i [ __ ] told you you know
and then they're like and i knew it and
i knew that was the right answer and it
finally came out yeah it's literally
everything like i'll be like hey make
sure to get this thing done because if
you don't i can already foresee this
happening yeah but those are dumb though
like you're not dumb when you're telling
me to do things it's stuff that i go i
know i need to do it i just can't do it
now or when you talk to people and
you're offending people all the [ __ ]
time and i'm going hey if you continue
this it's gonna go down this road when
do i ever offend anyone well it's not
that you're trying to offend it's just
the way you talk to people how do i talk
to people like a robot like how give me
example
do you have enough intelligence to drop
an example like that like that yeah like
that's annoying what what is do you have
enough intelligence to talk to people
and you don't really talk to people that
way but it comes off that way it can it
can come off a little condescending
and because i know you so well i'm like
oh he never means that because bart
doesn't operate on ego that way yeah um
but to the recipient if they don't have
that layer of understanding of who you
are as a core person then it comes off
very [ __ ] up
yeah and and i'll have to tell you like
hey just to let you know the way you
worded that or said that they might
misinterpret because we're all very
insecure people and we might read it
because we all operate the exact same
way and bart's like on [ __ ] planet
mars and be like they're gonna read it
this way so get ready to have another
explanation and you're like nah i should
be fine and then within that hour they
reply or there's like a back and forth
happening i'm like see i told you
that feels good
not really because i have to hate you
i hate you it looks funnier because you
have these big ass headphones on
um it's not it's not a ha ha but it a
little bit you know like it's a little
bit
it's not a full on ha ha because i have
to go in and clean it up and have to be
like no no no actually this is what what
he really meant blah blah blah they're
like oh okay and then i'm like you know
what they met was and then you're like
oh okay so it sucks for me because i'm
in the middle of it but um
yeah that little part of me goes ha ha
you stupid [ __ ] what i've been
beginning to realize is by listening is
that it seems like when guys do that i
told you so it seems like
um
guys still get the [ __ ] in on the stick
where else girls get to benefit from it
explain so like a very simple example i
feel a little skewed very simple example
would be like
like i go outside i'm like
hey babe i think she'll bring a jacket
and you're like nah that's fine right
30 minutes get another example 30 30
minutes later it's cold
can i have your jacket i'm like oh i
[ __ ] told you so but then now i'm
inconvenienced because i have to give
you my jacket no but it happens that way
with females too how where we'll say
like um i can't think of because these
are tropes now that you're talking about
no i'm talking about [ __ ] like this
any day
no these are tropes these are like
stereotypical things um
whereas for us we're more about like big
picture and like family because we're
not selfish the way guys are girls are
always thinking about for the most part
they're always thinking about the whole
family dynamic so we're thinking about
every single person and we try to be
prepared for every single person that's
like your dumb ass none of it that's why
your dumb ass is always using my [ __ ]
and i'm like wait you knew that this was
gonna happen why are you taking my [ __ ]
you're like i didn't have to bring my
because i knew you were going to bring
yours and i'm like [ __ ] you it's more
same thing you're more dependable yeah
you can't flip it and call it that it's
the same thing
what what of yours do i ever use
everything like what everything there
was something oh okay we were gonna go
pick tycob yeah i had my [ __ ]
[ __ ] super ice cold packed to the
brim with ice water enough for two
people yeah no no enough for one person
because i was [ __ ] thinking about
myself and myself only because this is
my only time to think about myself okay
okay and you're also [ __ ] geeky
enough to fill that [ __ ] up
yeah i don't give a [ __ ] what you call
it i'm [ __ ] prepared yeah you're the
[ __ ] guy
with the binder full of all the homework
and paper i don't give a [ __ ] i'm the
cool guy in class i don't have any paper
i'ma borrow something yeah go for it i
don't have to [ __ ] waste my time
begging for [ __ ] [ __ ] okay okay you
get go
call me a geek all [ __ ] day um
and you had your [ __ ] cup that
barbell one
filled to the brim also with ice and
water okay
we go into my car to go get tyka i have
his little [ __ ] sippy cup whatever
thing too yeah i put it on his little
arm [ __ ] chair of his little
thingamabob you're a good mom it's car
seat yeah i'm the best
um
you sit in and you start drinking my
water yours has a straw
you know what you drink with a straw
it's like it's different
it's refreshing it hits different like
you buy [ __ ] i don't even know where the
[ __ ] you buy that you bought that's not
my problem cool [ __ ] like that i don't
even know you just gotta do your
research dude i don't got time to
[ __ ] shop all day like you do i don't
got what i do more than you do all you
ever do is on pinterest all day i don't
know how even i don't even know how to
get to pinterest no you don't even know
how to [ __ ] post on instagram and
you're on that [ __ ] all day what are you
talking about you're just dumb that's
what i'm talking about that you're done
yeah i don't know i don't have these
skills yeah that's not my problem why do
i need to suffer because i'm cool i'd
get a lot of [ __ ] done in a day i can
take care of everyone else and myself so
i get the [ __ ] under the stick so you
got all things
covered but like let's say you need to
go
off the beaten path i got you covered
[ __ ] off i have gps what the [ __ ]
i'm talking about when you need to like
[ __ ] [ __ ] reverse terrain don't
worry about dirt rocks and stuff i got
you covered who was driving the other
half [ __ ] on that dirt road
i'll drive you know i drive better than
you anyway no but you don't even have
that you have to borrow my stuff just
like i got to buy yourself no i don't
have to yeah i don't have i have to i'm
going with the cool vehicle in terms of
vehicles i'm the one with the straw and
the
ice look at what you're turning to what
am i trying to do i'm the one with the
cool vehicle
i told you so
right now and end this podcast
i told you my vehicle is cooler
you're so stupid why you just became
nine
i've been nine
maybe eight i might be eight
yeah dude i don't think it's a i don't
think it's a male female thing i think
it's just
person versus person some some people
myself are just highly capable and very
independent and some people like you are
just dumb
you're you're independent
a hundred percent you can't do half the
things in the house you're always
telling me to do [ __ ] give me something
like you don't even know how to you know
not take the trash out
okay
okay you got me you know how to do that
you know how to do like this and that
and that and this
what's this and that that i don't know
all the things you always tell me to do
like what i forgot i called it up at the
time where you'll tell me to do
something and i'm like oh so you're
independent now so those times that i
call you guys because literally i take
care of everything in the [ __ ] house
a hundred percent i take care of all of
it good for you and i'm [ __ ]
overwhelmed with work because i'm also
the ceo of [ __ ] barber brigade for
you yeah that i'm going hey for this one
time because you're sitting on the couch
trying to figure out how instagram works
and you're like hey how do i put text on
this [ __ ] story and i'm like oh my
god can you please help me with one
thing instagram needs to come with a
tutorial
no they keep changing it a lot yeah
that's the only time i asked for help
would you have do you remember
it's so few when i ask you for help
probably told me to vacuum some [ __ ]
because you know how to do it because i
don't know how to vacuum you know how to
do those cool triangles like i know how
yeah i do you do of course who doesn't
show me i'll bet you can't do the whole
house i'm not showing you [ __ ] my
falling
you think i'm stupid yeah
oh my god you're so dumb or what about
uh was that one time you needed me to go
like switch the the breaker out or
something
that you couldn't figure out either no i
knew i did it but you didn't have to do
the breakers what breakers is it when i
had to call the [ __ ] community person
to come and fix it and the electrician
did it no some other thing it was like
something you need me to go like switch
the breakers out and then i did it
that's how few it is
that like you can't even remember that's
how little i involve you in anything i
need help with that's how little help i
need that's good isn't it really dope
yeah you're so lucky so where do where
do you get the [ __ ] end of the stick
explain that to me what do you have to
take my jacket all the time
what jacket it's [ __ ] a hundred
degrees right now with jackpot right now
the other day you just grabbed my
[ __ ] puffy jacket
because it's downstairs i didn't take it
off your body you didn't even use it i
put it there on purpose no i put them
all there on purpose oh my god i brought
your [ __ ] down too i put the puffy
jacket there on purpose all right
congratulations you know how to take
care of yourself fine
how does it feel to have such an
independent person honestly i love it
like what is the thing that you think i
can't do honestly
i
uh
will not compliment you
but but you're gonna compliment me no
but just know
the highest form of compliment
is that i chose you to be my wife
there's no greater compliment that i
could ever give [ __ ] off who do you
think you are no other like anything
else if i say like if i talk about your
beauty and intelligence your character
your ambitions wait tell me about the
character all of that what's the
character all of that falls way below
just the fact that i allowed you into my
kingdom fine what are your standards
my domain yeah what are your standards
what do you look for in a female what
were you looking for
how did i surpass that can i tell you
honestly how did i blow that [ __ ] out of
the water can i tell you honestly always
i don't know it's not much you're like i
don't know i just wanted her to walk on
two legs no i think like ever since i
was a kid
um maybe because i've been watching
[ __ ] period pieces since i was a kid
so my brain and like standards of stuff
is so weird i've always had this uh
worst nightmare that i was going to die
and then if i wait wait wait back it up
because uh you are
we all are like i could die any second
okay and because you had a feeling you
were gonna die young
um i just feel like i'm very vulnerable
like i'm gonna die anytime do you think
that has anything to do with the fact
that you had asthma flat feet you're
blind um you get sick really easily you
were very scrawny any of those no i
still with the superior pieces
okay
okay and uh i think i felt like i could
die at any time
so like ever since i was a kid
probably even when i was like
man even when i first started having
crushes
maybe
even like eight or nine
i always was nine what is that fourth
grade yeah i always
wanted someone that i felt like if we
got together
and we had a family and we started
building like a household
that um if i died i had a hundred
percent confidence she can carry it
i can see where that comes from
really where your mom
at that point your parents are divorced
and you see your mom [ __ ] smashing it
so it's not the period pieces
i mean it could be that could have
further emphasized it is it in these
period pieces is the king like the
[ __ ] almighty guy and then his
concubines or the chicks are just all
like these weaklings that need them
no maybe you saw that you're like no i
don't want that that's the king maybe i
saw that but it's also like the kings
get killed and then the tough queen
takes over oh that rules land that could
also be it but i think the fact that
your mom
was also a living example of that that
you're like oh they do exist
because like we all pick people that are
similar to our parents right because
that's what we grew up with so it feels
similar and it feels comforting you do
dress like my mom
oh really with these type of [ __ ]
nice rack
yeah my buttons weren't what they're
like yes my mom leaves her [ __ ] on
button all the time yeah i've seen her
titties a couple times yeah
i've seen your armpit hair just like
i've seen my mom's no you haven't
that's non-existent yeah but i think i
think of that so like you know like um i
think because of that
i've never felt like i've
i uh
was in line with the crowd so you know
like in every classroom you kind of have
like that the small version of the trope
right like you have like uh the popular
the prom queen like everyone knows she's
gonna be a prom queen because she's also
gonna be the cheerleader and then you
have the other chick who's like
attractive in her own way but you know
she's gonna be good at sports or she's
probably like a tomboy or something or
you have like the guy that's like the
blue ranger you know he's gonna be good
at computers like billy right like the
original power ranger like there's
always like that trope
um in almost every class that i had
starting in elementary
i never uh
knew that there was a geo out there for
you no i never really liked or my number
one pick wasn't the cheerleader it was
always the more athletic or like girl
that kind of had like the uh
that presence you know where like some
people might count it as a tomboy or
some might count as like more athletic
or whatever i always like i gravitated
towards that
ever since i was a kid she liked
masculine energy
a little bit so i think like um
yeah which is why i let you into my
domain
because there's a lot of chicks that are
that i mean that is valid you had to let
me in your domain however it doesn't end
there i had to
allow you into mine
no
yes 100 what the [ __ ] i'm on the vip
list no you're not dude
oh god did you see what you used to look
like yeah but the minute you hear
bar
you hear that
and man the [ __ ] seams of the thong
is bursting it's [ __ ] where are the
scenes
where are the seams on the thong i don't
think you've seen enough thongs
[Laughter]
that's how they come out
they're sewing like that it's a [ __ ]
eq
non-chafing thongs it's sewn real nice
yeah yeah and then
so like uh
yeah i let you into my domain because
you know
first time we met i've been going like
this
first time we met huh
i'm like
she'll do
you're like i'm gonna let my friend have
at her first yeah
and then
and then i'll do this for a few more
years
she passed
she passed the 100 point smog inspection
three years later yep i gotta make sure
that she passes all this mock that's
[ __ ] funny you're smog past smog
tested awesome thank you so much um i
was definitely not doing that with you
um but i'm happy that happened yeah i
don't really have
aha moment i mean uh c moments with you
because um
i don't know for that petty with each
other
you know because i think i think well
you're definitely feeling in the heart
right with the pettiness yeah like you
know like telling me to like get my tags
get my tags get my tags yeah never
ending pulled over you're like i [ __ ]
told you to get your goddamn yeah okay
but honestly like jokes aside it never
feels good because i'm like i don't want
to be right right because i'm trying to
prevent something from happening so when
it happens and i'm right i'm like [ __ ]
man i didn't want to deal with this so
it's never a
[ __ ] gotcha [ __ ] yeah you know it's
more of like a [ __ ]
i didn't want this happen only when it's
good [ __ ] where i'm like no come on
trust me it's gonna be good
those are the ones i do like
you know where where um but you're also
not a dowdy person so it's i don't
really have those stories either because
anytime i want to try something you're
always down for it yeah i'll try
anything twice
yeah you'll try anything twice so those
stories it's very few also but anytime
it's one of those i'm trying to prevent
something or i'm like come on do this or
whatever um i'm not going yeah
it's more like ah [ __ ] and i gotta help
this stupid [ __ ] clean all this
[ __ ] up yeah that's how i felt with
fitness
i was like man how do i how do i help
her i know it's really good for her and
then she it's going to be good for her
more than she can imagine yeah you can't
you can't help people if they don't want
it you can't yeah you really can't so
what it ended up happening remember it
put you pushed me away from it so much
i'm like [ __ ] hate the [ __ ] i hate
you and the [ __ ] and i want nothing to
do with it yeah burnt you out look at
you now you're awesome yeah because uh i
i i put myself through it and now it's
dope because you have so much knowledge
that now we're like both in it together
so we can bounce back and forth whereas
before it was like i [ __ ] hate this
[ __ ]
yeah so um i kind of like that we don't
have these moments where we're like aha
gotcha you know it just feels so
childish
and i don't know if we have a childish
relationship still fun
uh it's it's child like wonder that we
do have that's really cuny but we don't
we don't i don't ever want
i don't ever want to um celebrate any of
your shortcomings because that's just
stupid yeah because i'm like i'm living
with you why would i why would i want
that yeah if anything i want to elevate
you because
um
if you're better then you help me be
better and then once i'm better then i
help you be better and we just keep
pulling each other up higher and higher
so
for me to celebrate when you're not in
that space
it's just stupid on my part because i'm
like wait so i'm going to hold you down
and i'm going to keep myself down that's
just stupid yeah
my dad's still mad about stuff like that
like you know how
oh my mom like really loves fortune
tellers and then the fortune teller
told my mom like this is the year you
guys are going to get divorced
and then
that's the year they got divorced
and so my dad like to this day he's like
that [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] the fortune
teller told us we're gonna get
divorced this year
one
we can really not get divorced work on
the marriage or
if you want to get divorced let's get
divorced the year before or the year
after so at least we don't prove someone
right and until this day he's still like
i [ __ ] told you so
but then it's the he got the short
another or they both probably did they
both for sure and the fact that he's
holding on to something so dumb
instead of going i definitely like man
maybe i was a nuisance to put up with
maybe she tried to [ __ ] work it out
and i'm that [ __ ] obnoxious i don't
know if people
of that generation is that introspective
of course of course but to hold on to
something and repeat that it just sounds
so dumb it's also tough you know when
you think about it like the ideal
concept of marriage is you have
one chance
to make a good decision
and you know you're supposed to live
your life
with that decision
yeah and back in the day it happened a
lot quicker than how we do it now yeah
so it's actually really hard if you
think about it for marriage right like
people don't even hold on to the car
same car same house same friends same
clothes also commitment was was was
bigger back then right like people were
like i am devoting my life to you
but they also did have a bunch of
[ __ ]
side pieces
in that regard what do you think is
better
like do you like if someone like let's
say
in their marriage
rough feels
uh
irrep repairable right
they'd separate
and then uh because not only anyone
wants a divorce but it's like a
necessary thing if it gets there right
if it starts hurting your own personal
health
or
the people that have had that
and then
turn back around and have been able to
repair it even though they had this side
pieces i mean
and then they finish
well if we want to romanticize the whole
thing of course right the happily ever
after who doesn't want that yeah right
but that's not that's not realistic
um we all have like
we all know this we're all living living
in different phases of our lives right
like if you can find someone that's
aligned and living
their life in accordance to where yours
is and you guys can compliment each
other and it's harmonious of course it's
gonna work right but
um
there's just so many variables when it
comes to a relationship right like how
introspective is this person how
um how [ __ ] up was their family like
how [ __ ] up is their upbringing or how
healthy is it like there's just so many
different variables like it's it's it's
hard it's [ __ ] gnarly and i don't
think that there's one right way to do
anything right because like like we had
a really rough patch we worked it out
and we stayed together so yeah like you
can
remove yourself
from it and be like whoa that's really
hard work and you stuck it through
that's amazing
right but then you also have other other
stories where they stick it through and
it's toxic the entire way and now it not
only affects
the other partner it affects the family
and the family like the extended family
and it's just this big [ __ ] [ __ ] show
and it's like well they tried but their
their
capabilities
of fixing it was just not was just not
it or did they try you don't know
right they think they might have tried
but they're trying with whatever tools
they have in front of them
you know like someone like your dad
um the way you speak about him it seems
like he's changed so much but now he's
in his early 70s
you know and it took him up until he's
in the 70s and divorced and like alone
yeah um to figure all this [ __ ] out like
i don't know if he would have gotten to
this point if he was still married yeah
you know so like you don't i don't think
there's one right way sometimes i've
heard people say like it took the first
divorce
to help them make the second marriage
last forever and sometimes it takes the
fifth divorce to make that one the one
you know yeah so i don't think i don't
think anything has just one way to do it
um so yeah on paper well yeah happily
ever after you figured it out with the
same person good for you like how many
times do we hear those those couples
that like our high school sweethearts
like the side of me goes oh whoa that's
really cool like damn just just youtube
the whole time and you guys are happy
and in love that's [ __ ] beautiful and
then the other side of me goes what the
[ __ ] you've only had one dick one [ __ ]
this whole time you're not living life
dude you know
it just depends on i don't know how
that's outside of me so i don't say
stuff like that
you we've had podcasts where you talk
about i should have [ __ ] more people
yeah but that's a different podcast oh
this one's a different this one will
argue with that one oh good it's a
different time even though we talked
about it last month because i think like
when i hear about those i'm like man
those guys have a really good
relationship with themselves do they
yeah how do you know
um because i think in order to have a
good relationship you have to have a
good relationship with yourself first
yeah that's the first and foremost and
and
and that in that aspect when they're
high school sweethearts no i'm not
talking about a career you know like
everyone has so many lanes in their life
right like love career
like whatever you know i'm talking about
like they might be
dealing with stuff in the career side of
things or ambition side of things or
whatever but i'm talking about
um
the people that are able to
last and have a really good relationship
with someone else both romantic or
non-romantic i think it starts off with
uh both of them having a good
relationship
with themselves first so that
the because i think a lot of times the
relationships they
they don't last
because uh their own personal demons get
projected onto the other person choosing
someone that doesn't have like a long
lasting relationship is not a happy
person
but themselves no
yeah but i think people that are like uh
like for example um
like nick and tiff they've been together
since during high school
i feel like they they're they probably
have a really good relationship with
themselves and which is why they're able
to like deal with things and almost stay
a team because that's a that's the tough
part right like i think anytime you have
a team like even with mike jordan and
pippin and all those guys
um as much as everyone wants to have ego
everyone's a pro basketball player i
think ultimately like the famous story
is the night before the game jordan went
all over vegas looking for dennis rodman
he knows he needs him he's the best
player in the world he goes i know i
need him and that's a really good
relationship with yourself to even know
that yeah yeah versus going man [ __ ]
that guy this guy's
i'll score double the points and just
paying me extra like he didn't have like
a uh
a narcissistic view in the team dynamic
yeah that's very true you might have had
it in like the pr side of things or
career side of things yeah um but in
terms of in this dynamic i'm not better
than anyone i need this team i need my
pivot i need my ram i need this team to
make the [ __ ] work yeah and when i see
people that last a long time i'm like
wow that's
it's inspiring to me yeah
yeah but then you also have
relationships like what i perceive
because i'm not in it but what i
perceived my parents relationship was
where it was really cold
um i say that right and then i have i
also have glimpses or like memories of
like my dad always groping my mom yeah
and her going you know what i mean and
it's perceived like it's out from her
mom
excuse me
how do you know that look for my mom
because we flirt all the time
um but it felt like it was such a cold
relationship to me like it felt like
they were never together they never did
any date nights they'd never hung out
with each other it was always like my
mom's with us my dad's at work he comes
back she takes care of him and he goes
to work she goes she it's like every day
same thing over and over and over again
to the point where we were like yo why
don't you guys just get divorced like
you guys brought that up yeah because
they just felt like they were what do
they say like we didn't we didn't feel
like we didn't hear that like they
didn't like yell at each other like it
was never like that yeah but it just
felt really cold it felt like they were
both
um they both had things against each
other that they just were not happy with
did you guys talk about it amongst
siblings like hey with mom and dad of
course of course not but like
um
maybe maybe like in passing you'll hear
things like like because i wasn't that
like i wasn't old enough to have those
types of conversations with my elder
brother and sister
um
but i do recall those like either
conversations or i have those memories
of like going yeah i agree with that
that they should get divorced
um
but then they didn't
um and then once we all moved out then
they started like going on road trips
and they would hang out together all the
time and they really became a couple
so like stuff like that i'm like
should they have stuck it out that long
you know
i don't know
should they have should
should they have had like an open
relationship i don't know
i don't really i don't know i think i
think relationships are so [ __ ]
complicated
i think they're so complicated um
so i'm like [ __ ] if it's working for you
and both of you guys are happy and on
the same page and both of you guys are
agreeing to these relationship terms
then cool do you
happiness is harder to find too
right because it's like well and you're
the only one in charge of your own
happiness
yeah because like right now
like 3 30
3 30 45 seconds on this day
when uh like let's say this kid eats
candy he's happy right so he repeats his
happiness i love this every single day
and does it for six months
and then at 3 30 he goes to the dentist
and he gets 12 cavities he's like [ __ ] i
am sad
but it's like how did me
doing this repeated happiness thing
lead to the most
worst form of pain i've ever felt
so it's so tough how to like examine
happiness but on the flip side
your parents did
might have been the unhappy thing you
know 3 30 cold for 10 years straight
only for it to be really good at the end
and now they're really happy so it
wasn't like you needed that unhappiness
to be happy maybe and then like like how
do you measure happiness is it in the
moment or is it long term yeah it's like
it's so it's such a complicated thing it
is and we're constantly changing right
so like um my definition or my goal to
achieve this this ultimate happiness
that i want might have been to have a
kid
not that it is but it might have been to
have that and then once i have that i'm
like oh actually this is not what it
what i wanted you know because like you
have to
you have to measure your happiness
against something right like the kid
eating the candy like how do you know
that he was happy it's like oh well
because i felt this and that and like it
induced these
these memories or these things inside of
me that like i know i like that
um but even happiness is fleeting right
because like if he ate it at 3 30 every
single day for six months let's say he
didn't get these cavities then um two
years later he's gonna not want that
flavor anymore and if he's only holding
on to happiness
then he's gonna be like uh i don't want
this and i feel like that's where the
relationship is
if happiness is even fleeting is that
even an important thing to strive for
or is that more of a uh
i don't know if it's an isolated thing
or is it like a painkiller that
people want so i heard this thing that i
really liked
um and i'm gonna botch it up like i
always do but the gist of it is
we're gonna suffer in everything that we
do
right so like and and this was i think
like in a diet like the fit like meme
type of [ __ ] so it's like um you're
gonna be unhappy regardless of what you
do so if you're gonna eat all this junk
food then you're gonna be unhappy with
your body right um but if you start
working out you're going to be unhappy
training but you might be happy with
your body so just pick the suffering
that you want oh like the like those
mean memes that are like pick your heart
yes like marriage is hard divorce is
hard yeah they're both it's the same
thing yeah like uh getting overweight
dieting is hard right
like those ones yeah yeah like
everything that's
worth
experiencing is gonna be hard yeah the
same way it's gonna be just as rewarding
you know i feel like the harder this the
thing is
at the end of it all it's super
rewarding like i know i think that's
what what keeps me um
striving for whatever goal that i have
or working really hard for [ __ ] because
i'm like [ __ ] i [ __ ] hate it and
you're gonna hear me vent about it
you're gonna hear me complain about it
i'm gonna [ __ ] make a fuss out of it
just with you because you're my [ __ ]
life partner i don't really do that
outside of our circle um but yeah i'm
gonna be miserable but i won't stop
because i'm like this is just a means to
an end like this is just something i
have to go through and i know i'm gonna
come out of it and i know it's gonna be
worth it yeah like i've never felt
honestly i've never felt like when i'm
in the [ __ ] most shittiest position
i've never felt like i gotta i gotta
stop like this is this is it like i'm
not gonna go through with it you know
because then i go no i know i have to go
through with it like i know it's gonna
pay off i know it's gonna be good even
though that little voice of like it's
gonna be good it's really tiny and i
have to [ __ ] fight to search it a lot
i'm just like [ __ ] it i'm just gonna put
my head down and do what i gotta do
yeah i think for me
my north star is uh productivity
so like
i know happiness is fleeting i know
sadness is fleeting
and i think those are bad measures of
uh
if what you're doing is good for you
right just kind of like that kid example
right even though as a kid it's simple
to
like now that you're an adult it's easy
to look at a kid and go eating candy
every day is bad for you yeah right
right duh the kid doesn't think so why
this tastes so good and then when you're
an adult same thing a senior citizen is
going to look at you what you're doing
every day that is so bad for you why are
you doing that but you could be 35 and
you're like what are you talking about
this makes me feel great every day until
the moment hits and then you're like oh
my god i have this cavity in life and
then the 80 year old is like i told you
right yeah there's always that
what i noticed to help me be um
gauge what's actually important is
productivity so like you know in if i
use that like hard meme as an example
like marriage is hard divorce is hard
pick your heart or dieting is hard
diabetes is hard pick your heart i think
for me it's
whatever i'm doing
if it's productive
and there's a a result that is going to
benefit me long term for it i'm the same
regardless if it's unhappy or happy at
the moment i just have to do more of
that yeah if there's something that i'm
doing
that later uh
i know i need to undo it
i should try
not to do it regardless of our happy or
unhappy right so for example i don't
know if i think that complicated because
that's actually really hard like the kid
example right like when you're like okay
if i or like right now like i'm i'm fat
right now but i know it's controlled
because i'm doing this to do for videos
because i'm we're going to start this
program so i do want to start a little
bit heavier so that i can show people
when i jump on the get lean program that
i can lose the weight right but uh for
example if i wasn't in control of my
weight
when you start gaining weight
you constantly go oh man
i need to undo this because i remember
when i was in college i was this weight
and then so
if i keep moving in a direction no
matter how happy i am
but at the bottom of my heart i know
i have to undo this then i know i'm
going down an unproductive path
yeah yeah um
yeah i don't know if mine is that
complicated but for me the way i've
always navigated life was i need to be
making progress like i need to feel that
there's progress being made whether
that's um in like school in my work life
in my relationship with friends in my
relationship romantically uh how i'm
living you know how how i'm living
like it even started this simply where i
was like okay this is this is the this
is the way i'm gonna get my cars right
i'm not i'm never gonna downgrade with
my cars because that that for me was
like a physical manifestation of
progress because i'm like i need to be
able to afford more expensive cars
because i'm like what
i'm a teenager
you know so a car is a huge purchase for
me so i'm like i'm never gonna downgrade
because then that's when i'm heading
down the wrong path so i always needed
to feel like i was growing in something
and if i'm not growing then i need to
change it
so like with my friend circle if i if i
felt like i was the smartest person not
and this sounds really [ __ ] up and
don't take this i just don't know how
else to explain it but if i felt like i
was the smartest person in my friend
circle i'm like oh [ __ ] i need i need
different friends i need to remove
myself from the circle because i'm not
getting [ __ ]
um and the same like i would try to
contribute as much as i knew into the
relationships right or like if i'm
dating anyone a lot of those like uh
super successful people always say like
um surround yourself tell me who your
firefriends are and i'll tell you what
your future is yeah
um and even in my like romantic
relationships i know where i wanted to
go i knew what my next steps were and
i'm like this is where i'm headed are we
going down the same path and if i see
that they want to
they just don't have the resource or the
knowledge and i'm like cool let me let
me try to help you let me let me pull
you with me and if if i felt like i was
pulling too much and i'm like whoa we're
not we're not going down the same path
see you later sayonara um and in
everything everything i ever did i'm
like i need to feel some sort of
progress if i don't
it's not for me and it was just that
simple like it was just these little
markers that i would have that i'm like
i need to feel like i'm growing
i like i like it i love growth
i love change
and um
and i like surrounding me surrounding
myself around things and people that
like that too
yeah i think um
for me that that feeling of growth and
progress
is so important to the point that
i think that's actually what helps me
through burnout
you know like there's times where i'm
burned out for like years
you know two years three years
um but i think
but me knowing
that
all of my actions are adding up to
something greater yeah
no matter how shitty or unmotivated or
uninspired that i feel now
i can i i will still be able to get my
body like through the emotions like i
feel like i'm definitely like driving
through mud like yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
i don't want to be here it sucks yep
because you you're i was just going 80
miles an hour earlier and now i'm like
oh i hit sludge you know yeah and the
[ __ ] tires are just spinning
sometimes yeah but i'm like but they're
still going but i know what's what what
comes you know even if i just put one
foot in front of the other
so through burnout like i've been able
to still keep pushing for two three four
years as much as i need you know to like
to because i know that emotions are
fleeting and i'll come and go and if you
push hard enough you actually fall in
love with the mud
and once you fall in love with the mud
that's when the most dangerous person
comes to life because the person that's
like welcomes the pain that welcomes the
hell then they're like [ __ ] yeah and all
of a sudden you're sprinting in the mud
now yeah
i can relate to that pretty hard um
i've never i've never labeled anything
as burnout i don't know that feeling
like i i can understand the feeling i
can understand what you're saying but
like i've never told myself that this
feeling of this heaviness or this tired
or this fatigue or this frustration or
whatever all [ __ ] compiled into one
day or space or period in my life is
burn out like i i don't label it that
way i just i don't know it's burned out
i only know
when i've been burnt out yes yes after
this because i'm going so hard right i
don't even know i'm burnt out right so
whenever i feel that way and i'm
complaining and i'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] on everything um i notice that
i start celebrating
internally i start celebrating and
leaning into the things that make me
happy because the things that are making
me happy are so [ __ ] small so it
could be something as small as like this
design that finally came together that i
[ __ ] love and i'm like oh my god this
is a [ __ ] huge victory finally out of
this [ __ ] i'm like here's the [ __ ]
lotus flower that just [ __ ] sprouted
from the [ __ ] nastiest dumpy swamp
[ __ ] and i i look at him like this is
the [ __ ] best [ __ ] ever and i try to
hold on to that and go okay i'm gonna
keep [ __ ] going for that next feeling
and i really do try to like
i don't know i just noticed that i'll
like really like try to cling on to this
small feeling so that i can just keep
[ __ ] charging forward i don't know if
that's healthier no it's like breath
control
breath control oh breath control yeah
you know when they say like when [ __ ]
hits the fan and things are [ __ ]
crazy like you know in jiu jitsu scuba
diving all that stuff it's like okay the
most craziest thing in the world
is
you feel you're stressed the [ __ ] out
you're gonna die if you're can breathe
you're technically good you're still
alive yeah so let's start with that so
any type of like crazy uh like um
emergency
protocol it always starts with breath
okay you feel like you're gonna die can
you breathe
cool can you control your breathing can
you breathe at will like one two three
four cool
that's your baseline your life now let's
rebuild let's build build build build
build build so i think that's your like
birth control we're like okay there's
this little wind
that's cool
can i have another little one another
little win yeah and then it start the
wind starts building it feels it's my
progress again yeah cause i'm like cool
there was a beginning and an end to it
and i saw it to its completion even
though it's such a small [ __ ]
drop in this big ass ocean i'm gonna
focus on the small drop because there
was this one drop that finally made its
way
through if i can do this again i could
probably if i did this once i could
probably do it again and i'm like
let's get back in it
and then dive back in yeah
yeah
life's crazy man life's so crazy and um
it's cool to have people that are down
to open up about their craziness
like their struggles and [ __ ] is
everyone's struggling dude literally
like we just had dinner with um our
friend's parents
it was our friend and he brought along
his parents and i [ __ ] love his
parents yeah like they were they're also
fellow entrepreneurs um but they're in
their what like 60s
i don't even know i can't even guess
yeah they look so [ __ ] fly and hip um
and they were telling us about their
origin stories and all their struggles
and their perceived failures and stuff
and i'm like whoa
this is so [ __ ] rad because like
we're all [ __ ]
guessing at life everyone goes through
it and no one has an easy life that's
the thing where i think there's this big
this big misconception you know like the
the famous term must be nice yeah [ __ ]
those people there is no such thing as
nice because everyone has a difficult
life yeah barbara what about the people
that are born into like all this
privilege and all this money they got
difficult life too they have different
problems absolutely they probably don't
know how to connect with their parents
they're probably on [ __ ] drugs they
probably see the craziest wildest [ __ ]
they don't know how to they don't know
how to create
actual lasting relationships they're
they have different set of problems for
sure yeah and it sucks because that type
of thinking
um it's lifeline
it's actually very selfish
when you think must be nice
what you're saying is everyone's life
should be as shitty as yours
or yours should be as bomb as everyone
else's versus i think the understanding
that everyone has a tough life is the
more empath uh empathetic approach where
you're like you know what we all share
different struggles maybe the physical
difficulties are different but what
we're all going through emotionally
is it's it's real you know i don't know
if the it must be nice is selfish i
think that must be nice is lazy
because they're going laziness comes
from selfishness is it yeah
so what makes a person lazy
it's a selfish perspective
i guess so
yeah i guess i guess it is lazy i mean
uh it is selfish right um like like
think of think of the immigrant parent
right because now the common thing is oh
you're not lazy you're just unmotivated
right that's the that's these like
entrepreneurial motivations just keep
doing [ __ ] entrepreneurial meme right
that everyone preaches you're not lazy
you're just unmotivated that's just a
nice what about all the immigrant
parents
who are completely unmotivated you think
people want to [ __ ] run dry cleaners
or wash dishes in the back of a
restaurant but they work 12 hour days to
make it happen for their family right
they don't have time to figure out what
the [ __ ] their passion what they're
motivated about yeah they just keep
going
that is unselfish that's the epitome of
unselfishness i gotta put food on the
table for you yeah
right right but when you're going i
can't work unless i unless it it aligns
unless it brings a fire to me yeah
that's selfish yeah because like it's
about you so that's why i think like um
laziness is rooted in selfishness um and
that's only coming from the person
that's going must be nice because i
think it's okay to be selfish and that's
what i'm alluding to where there must be
a nice
concept comes from it's a comparison
right it's not from like i'm gonna focus
on my own lane
and uh i'm gonna do what i can and and
benefit my own life
the must be nice comes from lane
comparison like
oh must be nice to have four-wheel drive
and this you know
it's like okay no you don't have
four-wheel drive but what can you do so
if you kept if you kept your eyes on
your own lane you would never say it
must be nice because there's nothing to
compare to and that's why i'm saying it
comes from a point of selfishness
because you're comparing it to something
and you feel like you're getting the
[ __ ] another stick yeah yeah
yeah that's [ __ ] annoying i can't
relate
i can't relate ever
like i don't know if uh
if michael jordan ever would say some
[ __ ] like that yeah no because he's
making it happen for himself yeah cause
those those are also people that think
um they don't
have control over their life
because it's like if you know you have
control over your life then
you understand that you have the
capacity to change it
and you have control over your mind and
your thoughts
and if you have control over that you
can change those as well
yeah i think that's the thing that needs
to be taught the first thing actually
for kids you have control over your life
that you have control
everything is in your control yeah
um
and i think that would help out because
i think that's like the proper framework
first understanding
everything is in your control
and then now that you understand that
then you can add tools to that
understanding
you know
versus i feel like a lot of people they
uh especially i think in our generation
we're like we're i think we're the first
generation that is the first
most college educated
and then they go okay cool i know a ton
of [ __ ]
but because they don't feel like they're
in control how do i apply that
i know how to apply everything i learned
even now you don't think that happens i
think there's a turn so now i think the
turn is uh the more common theme is like
you don't need school right you don't
need traditional institutionalized
education what you do need is
self-education
that start that's control right okay
cool maybe i don't need to pick um all
these like
four semesters worth of prereqs and gen
like ge like i'm gonna just directly
learn what i wanna learn to do what i
wanna do and then you're putting control
back into your life
you know
so i think there's definitely a huge
shift of that which is pretty freaking
amazing yeah where people like i'm gonna
do this i'm gonna learn about this
um and even the the people that like
travel like crazy like finding
themselves that's dope
like the the dope part to that is you're
doing something you're doing it you're
controlling your life you're trying to
discover yourself there's things i don't
know about myself i need to put myself
in situations to discover myself
um i think the problem is when people
are discovering themselves for extended
periods of time where they're not doing
anything with the discoveries and now
those become crutches that's different
but i think when people like
okay the next month two or three
whatever i'm gonna discover myself cool
i know who i am now boom hit the ground
running that's [ __ ] dope yeah yeah
yeah and i think we also have to get
kind of
going past that also getting this is
something i'm trying to um learn
currently is also being comfortable with
when you understand who you are
also uh being nimble enough to know that
you're gonna change and continue to
change that part's a trip huh yeah
because you're never the same person
ever yeah and and you shouldn't be
right because how i thought how i was
thinking about life
maybe even last month i could have came
across
a really inspiring or compelling story
or person or experience that what i
thought last month has changed me
completely forever
and like being okay with going like [ __ ]
i don't know who i am at this moment
every five
years i realized the last game of chess
i was playing was checkers
isn't that crazy that is crazy yeah like
whatever chess it's crazy
whatever chess i'm thinking i'm playing
now i'm like oh [ __ ] it's so [ __ ]
sophisticated you think you're just
about to figure it out and it goes
bam
five years later i'm like that [ __ ] was
actually child's play you know yeah like
every phase like when we
when i graduated college you know when i
got into college you know you talk to
the friends that are still in high
school i'm like dude just wait when you
get into college it's just [ __ ] crazy
you come out of college and you get into
the workforce
you tell all the friends that just went
into college trust me college
work is crazy
literally every like five years you're
like
that [ __ ] is child's play yeah which is
dope because some people might not even
feel that some people would be like
same old [ __ ] different day yeah and
that's why i think that also helps me
because no matter how hard things get
i know one day
i'll think it's child's play
so i'm like it's just my perspective
right now
um but i know if i go through it
it'll be easy one day yeah just like how
everything else was yeah sometimes
though the [ __ ] you're going through is
[ __ ]
heavy you feel like damn every day
did this day just double in time i
thought there were 24 hours in a day why
does it feel like there's 48 today
like his time going slow like you just
feel like it's never gonna end
there's some there's there's heavy [ __ ]
like that mine never feels
uh it slows down almost feels like it
speeds up even at your darkest times
that's like i don't have enough time i
feel like even at your darkest hour
i don't know if my days are that dark
anymore
or just ever
i'm just talking about just the darkness
like the heaviness
that's what i'm emphasizing on maybe
because we're gonna continue to have
that
we're never not gonna have a super dark
day yeah that's true life just happens
you know like what's gonna happen today
like dude i i i think about this
sometimes i'm like [ __ ] how am i going
to film my mom passes away
you know i'm going to feel
dude that's just that's not going to be
a happy day that might not even be a
happy year
like who knows how do you want to
celebrate it
we gotta make it fun
[ __ ] bring out all the vibrators
because she said she had vibrators in
her drawers she'll make a pinata out of
her face and everyone gets a whack
that's horrible no
but she like that right like
like it's inevitable like we're gonna
have [ __ ] dark days yeah we all are
yeah and just [ __ ]
the mortality is really it is gonna end
the mortality is real too because like
all of the all of our people are our age
um their parents their uncles
starting to get more hospital visits oh
god it's just i'm like man this is
because you know when you're a kid
and you think you're gonna live forever
when you look at someone that's like 30
something you're like man that's old
you're like oh [ __ ] they're adults
and then you look at your grandparents
and you're like man you're really old
and then now i'm like oh [ __ ] i'm the
adult that i used to look at and my
parents
who used to be the strong adult is now
the withering grandparent
it's like wow
how have the turn tables yup how have
the turntables that shit's crazy yeah it
is crazy
i don't know man that's why like we can
get into the weeds of all this [ __ ]
right yeah
and then i go
but i'm here now
and like i just want to make the best of
every day and sometimes it's [ __ ]
hard because i find myself thinking
about all these other things and go wait
wait wait wait i gotta come back down to
here like right now
and like technology and work and all
these other things just make it so hard
so i'm glad that we're like gonna take a
vacation why does technology make it
hard
because it's it's all curated [ __ ] that
you're very interested in
yours doesn't look like mine yeah and
it's made just for me i love you
everything that i lost on instagram real
quick yeah cause it's all my favorite
things that i picked myself
if it was if i was on your instagram
[ __ ] i'm not spending five minutes on
that because i'm not interested
but it's curated yeah to my likings
so it's just it's just whispering in my
ear every [ __ ] five minutes i'm not
on it hey baby
do you have a time where you are like
you want to get rid of it get rid of
social media all the time every day
every time i'm on it that i find myself
being on it a little too long so it's a
defining moment for you to stop it
forever
when
i'm living the life
right
carefree
where i feel like i've taken care of my
family my immediate family i've taken
care of my extended family i see that
they're living
and this is selfish on my part because
who's to say that they're not right now
right but they're living at the standard
that i want them to be living at right
they're close to us or at least we're
close to each other they're they're in
uh what i consider
uh a better neighborhood um like all my
all my
all of that's taken care of
do you think that's inevitable and then
working is a choice you think it's
inevitable that everyone is going to be
on social media
like i can talk
i could totally see people that are
addicted to social media right of course
and then they're like you know what one
day when i'm retired we're all addicted
so they work hard
they retire now they're sitting on the
beach now they're back on their phones
is it like i don't know i don't know
maybe but i don't know if i have that
that in me i think when i make my
decision to do something it's it's
pretty set it's hard for me to go back
to it
you know and then because i'm so
self-aware of the decision and why i'm
making it yeah i might have those
relapse moments not where i necessarily
go back but where i go oh man i miss
that thing
you know and then if i let's say i do
relapse for whatever reason let's say i
do get on back on it then i'll remind
myself that dude nah this this ain't it
and then i'll go back
yeah but um i don't have an addictive
personality personality um
once i set my mind to it because my
reasoning is really good that it makes
sense to me and it and like i can pull
back and see where i want my life to be
and how this one thing is preventing me
from that thing
then yeah without a doubt i i don't
i don't think i'll ever need it
it'll be it'll be uh interesting to see
what role it plays in like taika's life
um and like our future kid if we ever
have another one
like their life and seeing how like we
can control that right because like
it might be weird like if i'm completely
off it and they're super addicted to it
and i'm like completely disconnected i
don't even understand what's going on
anymore like i kind of don't want that
either yeah because for the the next
generation like tiger's generation
social media might not even be a choice
yeah you know i mean like for us what
wasn't a choice is telephones
right everyone's house had a telephone
no one no one was going um nah i'm gonna
be off that telephone yeah i'm addicted
to my telephone has too much dopamine in
that thing like everyone had a telephone
it's just part of his existence right
you just know any business you want to
contact hit 4-1-1 you can get their
number you can call them yeah because
we're born into the telephone life
taika is going to be born into the
social well he is he's born into the
social media life where everything is
social media connected so he's not even
going to world know a world outside of
it and if he's if that is second nature
to him
then for us to be connected with him
yeah we might also have to stay
connected somehow for sure but i think
once um
and this is me speaking from my ass
obviously because who knows where
anything's going it's about to be stinky
[ __ ] you
um
but i think just setting those
boundaries and going like okay what am i
like how people like let you use it
don't let it use you type of thing yeah
but we'll see i don't know taking it one
day at a time
that's all you really can do
i think when you try to take too many
things on and think of the future too
much
that's like an uh what is it an uh
paralysis
over analysis is paralysis or whatever
that kind of like is so daunting that
you're just like i don't i don't even
know what it what to do what a start
where to go yeah i think they said a
little bit more intelligently than that
but yeah i get what you're saying yeah
yeah you're just as stupid as i am so of
course you know i'm really smart
um so yeah taking it one day at a time
makes things a lot more digestible
i think taking one thing at a time but
also knowing what you're where you're
going what your goal is yeah and then i
think your goal is also uh
it's relative to your goal muscle
so for example um you know like i i've
noticed that like uh
like financial investors because i've
been following them a lot
um
people that have been through
uh uh have not been through recessions
and barren bull markets
they are less calm
you know oh [ __ ] this is going crazy
what do we got do it we gotta like
like like mast sell or do whatever right
people that have been like warren
buffett been through tons of them they
just see it they understand what's
happening and so when they see like oh
we gotta pull out now when they see a
recession yeah when they see a recession
come it's not a bad thing they go oh i
just adjust my game plan
versus i think people that don't have
that muscle exercise yet
recession
is a bad thing or this is a bad thing
like check is versus your chest
yeah it's just when you're when you get
when you're when you've had multiple
cycles of that chest
then you can think longer and longer
term without it freaking you out but i
think you should it should only you
should only set your goals
as far away
as it's a form of encouragement and
happiness
and not
a form of anxiety because then your day
to day is not going to be good yeah
yeah it is going to suck
anyway
on that no no
we're done okay good good i'm going to
ask you [ __ ] thank you guys so much for
listening we'll catch you guys next week
bye